[Music]
music boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host I'll sock in
super excited to be talking about the
future of healthcare we have dr. Tom Lee
joining us on the show hello hello hey
thanks so much for coming on really
appreciate it huh it's been a long time
coming yeah a long time coming up I'm
super pumped we were finally doing this
for those that don't know Tom's
background he's a physician entrepreneur
and man of mystery he's the founder
executive chairman of one Medical Group
which is committed to providing the best
primary care through exceptional quality
a world-class experience and second and
none technology most recently he started
Galileo which is building the future of
healthcare and you can find all the
links in the bio below to one medical
calm as well as Galileo dot IO and his
LinkedIn profile all right Tom let's
start things off with one of our
favorite questions ask our guests what
are your thoughts on the direction of
our world I already was joking about
before us so I can't say that anymore
the direction of our world
it is definitely spinning and orbiting
in the context of time not much has
changed but I would say you know if
there was an inflection point on life in
Earth it feels like we're in some type
of inflection point so that would be my
short answer tell us more about the
flight inflection point well you know
you know there's this whole trend
towards expansion singularity obviously
right and if you look at humans as an
expansion form of that and what we're
doing to earth what we're doing the
information in tech you see some of that
fabric splitting in society on our
planet and in how we are just living our
lives that you know you really can kind
of see this fork in the road of does the
world actually go in a negative
direction and humanity go in a negative
direction or does it go positive and
that hopefully was a little bit more I'm
lifting but it does feel like we could
kind of go down either at this stage and
one is very plausible yeah what do you
think is needed for us to go down to
positive for it's a great question I'm a
little bit concerned our natural
momentum will carry us down the negative
path you know it's just it's hard to
change human behavior human instincts
are natural kind of biologic wiring but
if we were to say hey what could [ __ ]
towards the positive you know is this
kind of human factor the bonds of social
fabric are we actually going to pull
together and really try to solve some of
the tougher problems and tougher choices
so you know I think it's one of those
things where if you can kind of you know
as a collective start to influence you
know our mindset probably more than
anything you know that's kind of my two
bits
yeah what would be an important thing to
influence with mindset and that social
fabric side to get to that positive work
yeah you know you know there's so many
ways to cut this we're really at a super
high level but if I were to say hey you
know what would be kind of an influence
that would be kind of cool you know just
a broader awareness and practice of
mindfulness I think could really start
to tighten up the fabric of humanity a
little bit more and you know I was never
really a woowoo type of person but you
know it's just pretty clear and apparent
that the you know the way our society
structured the way tech influences our
human brain the the the counterbalancing
force of meditation mindfulness puts
people in a better place of
connectedness and I think that's what
we're kind of lacking yeah yeah that's a
good one
definitely now I want to know about your
journey so who were you growing up that
got interested in medicine
oh let's see yeah I was not naturally
interested in medicine in fact I was
probably not interested in medicine
because all my family was in medicine my
parents were both doctors my uncles and
cousins were all physicians at some
levels so I was a little bit more of a
contrarian and I loved the sciences I
loved helping people so that would
naturally speak towards a medical career
but I also was a bit of a contrarian
where I didn't want to do what my
parents were doing so if anything I kind
of almost thought about doing a graphic
design career that was kind of some good
you know was appealing to me but
ultimately it was like hmm you know what
kind of make a living at and medicine
seem like a more pragmatic choice so I
rolled the dice you know I I didn't love
the sciences frankly when I was in
school I thought that it was not really
taught well and it was just too micro
and it wasn't contextual for the way my
brain works yes and so some brains
really love that [ __ ] they love the
detail and memorization of things and
mine was I don't understand how this any
of this works or why it works and so the
patterns didn't make any sense to me so
so basically you know I roll the dice
went to med school and then once I got
into med school I was like I love this
profession because I can study and the
the practice of the studying of medicine
is an art and a science translated to
human care so it was much more of a
direct connection you know g-proteins
and you know biochemistry and p-orbitals
you know it was hard for me to see how
it helps you as a person but you know
anatomy physiology you know you know
microbes you know that kind of stuff
made a lot more sense to me so that was
kind of when it was crystallize that oh
yeah Madison is kind of cool and and I
really go into medical school with you
know a lot of you know curiosity and fun
yeah there's almost a sweet spot then in
terms of one's understanding of the
medical field at the micro level as well
as at this macro Abbe more abstract the
application of the science and the art
to you to the to the exact state of each
end
humans physiology at the moment that's
so then so then it's it almost seems as
though it's it's it was to swing
ourselves more towards the direction of
the application of all the that micro
stuff is what is super-important okay so
then when you were going through the
process of okay it was Yale first then
it was Stanford and then it was the
University of Washington kind of you
know you kind of moved the hats around
oh yeah the hats around okay okay so but
those three where's where and then you
were at UCSF yeah okay and that was
clinical faculty and you were doing
Epocrates as well the chief medical
officer there correctly and all these
kind of weird to have give us a
synthesis of that time period for you
Wow so well yeah maybe I'll describe the
arc which might have a little bit more
of a natural thread but maybe let's
start with the discipline of medicine
forces you to go micro to our point
right so you study the practice of
medicine but increasingly the way the
health care system is architected it
encourages you to increasingly get
specialized do research and focus on the
micro and so when I was doing my medical
training in Seattle as a med student you
know I was doing rural and her medicine
and then I did my residency at the in
Boston at Brigham very kind of a cordon
Airy care system complex care the
increasing pressure was too specialized
and I think my innate nature and biology
was to be more of a macro person and
solve bigger more population oriented
problems so there was a dissonance there
and so and and plus you know health care
quality and service and cost were just
out of control so to me that more
captivating problem was not you know how
do I really knew once this drug for this
disease but how do I redesign the care
delivery system for the popul
and so it was an orthogonal switch and I
was like I got to do something different
and so I rolled the dice got into
business school and fortunately was you
know except to Sanford and then that's
really kind of what launched kind of
most of my entrepreneurial career which
was you know I had the kernel of one
medical in my head but I was an academic
clinician I had no tech background no
business background I was a pretty
classic position where we didn't really
understand or respect non clinical
arenas particularly the business arena
yeah Wow
okay so we are so frequently pressured
into the specialized forces that it is
hard for us to take a macro generalist
perspective on how to redesign
population-wide healthcare systems and
so that is where the going to Stanford
and it's going getting into the process
of hippocrates and then ended up
founding one Medical Group and so that
was 12 and a half years ago yeah don't
remind me but yeah these time flies and
give us give us a walk through of how
you envisioned the redesigning of the
healthcare system well the vision was
always the same which is if you can have
a nice high touch experience around
hotels restaurants coffee bars whatever
why is the doctor's experience so crappy
and then separate from that how do you
improve the quality of care which most
patients can't realize right they
usually associate a long wait in a bunch
of degrees as quality and that may or
may not necessarily be true so I wanted
to also design a higher-quality model
and I was concerned about healthcare
costs so how can you design a higher
touch primary care model that reduces
total cost of care so I was really
interested in all these three elements
so there's the service side that
patients can appreciate but there's also
an examination of quality and cost and
so
you know ultimately it's just like any
other arts priority you know if you have
a vision you got to figure how to build
it and the first version was pretty
scrappy and low-cost I knew nobody would
fund it so I self-funded it and and you
just get early prototyping right it's
like no different than software
development except it's the service
design experience and so we did a
lightweight office it was higher touch
you know I was doing the blood draws the
answering the phone sending out the
bills but it allowed me to learn
everything about running a practice yeah
so you just kind of dive in figure it
out and fortunately we figure it out and
then you know every year you just
improve many more things and so now
everybody goes gosh it's amazing
whatever and you know it's just this
whole stepwise process there's no kind
of silver bullets or things you can just
do and yeah yeah suddenly you've got
voila medical yeah so take us take us
back to when you were doing we were
wearing all the hats you're learning
about the processes of running your own
clinic and then what was it like then
designing it for optimizing the patient
experience and then also the the the
cost yeah yeah yeah I mean that's kind
of the weird thing about one medical is
you know people experience it as a
high-touch you know a warm experience
it's very thoughtful and that's
certainly hard to do and you got to you
know think about hospitality and we
learned a lot about looking at
best-in-class hospitality across
multiple industries but that side is
hard but then you got to run it against
an economic model in a lot of you know
free market economies such as restaurant
tours or whatever you just charge a
price premium to that that's big enough
to support the labour cost to do a
high-touch model in health care because
reimbursement is is somewhat negotiated
and fixed right through contracts you
don't have the luxury you can't charge a
higher
in the insurance world for a higher
touch visit right it's the same it'll
reimburse the same so you have to really
think about lean and lean operations and
so most people don't know that one
medical is doing you know 10x the
service at about a third the labor cost
of traditional doctor's office and that
allows us to really kind of power the
practice to make it work yeah but you
know it's a little bit of left and right
brain you just got a you know hammer on
both sides how does it feel and then you
know what's the math look like and the
math is hard to do like most people
don't know the math and medical
practices you know in fact most of
delivery they don't have a great
understanding of the economics of what
things cost partly because they haven't
been held accountable for it the way we
pay for health care meaning in the
traditional insurance world you get paid
for stuff plus you know X right and so
you're not you're not paid for saving
money underneath the hood like you know
it's just not the mindset of most
provider groups yeah so 10x the service
one-third the medical costs let's get in
let's do the math we'll do the math in a
moment the patient experience run the
NDI should be up right now do you see it
okay so so the patient experience itself
you guys have how many of these I think
we're almost eighty or so in rush you
SAT across the US and you call them
clinic offices or clinics yeah okay I'm
who you are okay we have different
dialects and so um one of the things
here is that you the setting doesn't
feel like a medical office correct that
one of the key design for the patient
experience yeah I mean it's you know I
mean it's weird that this is considered
now you know what people should be
aspiring to but it just seemed obvious
you know 12 years ago plus but you know
the average doctor's office back in the
day was you know it's still what most
doctors offices are you know small
cramped somewhat faded chairs and dirty
carpeting with old outdated magazines
and
when L am in plastic you know it's just
it if you're sick you know the
environment matters
and I think people don't appreciate the
importance of that and or what it
signals yeah that the physician actually
carries right and so you know if you
think about most physicians we're
trained as scientists and so it's not to
the fault of the physicians we're just
mostly trained as scientists and we
don't fully appreciate the environmental
context of things and almost perhaps
diminish it you know if you had an
average researcher or professor it's not
like they have very glamorous offices
they're used to the quality of the work
standing for themselves not the veneer
of it but when you're a patient and
you're truly designing for a patient
experience and you want them to feel
cared for you do have to pay attention
and I think that's kind of one thing
that we said when we started off with
one medical yeah 80 from 1 to 80 I love
it across the United States and and the
appearance of these as you know as we
get to look at them it it it it shouts
we we care we care about the design of
what you've walked into and like your
feeling of being at home here yeah
and so that's huge and then now I want
us to hit on how are the the practices
so now I'm in I'm getting I'm getting
them registered I'm a really enjoying
your ambiance but then I'm also going
into where I'm actually working with the
physicians in the back and in the rooms
and whatnot and then now teach us about
the practices that one medical will get
to the math stuff in a moment but teach
us about the practices that one medical
physicians kind of embody with the deep
art and science yet medicine for each
physician for each patient who also if
you think about an ideal doctors
experience has many many different
elements you know obviously the
reception the way that people answer the
phone the way you're greeted are a
portion of it but ultimately people are
there to see the physician right or the
health care
practitioner that they're booked to see
and if that clinical encounter is
mediocre or low-quality it doesn't
really matter right and so ultimately
the experience into the physician is an
important part of it but it's not the
most important part the most important
part is the actual clinician that you're
seeing and so there's always a trade-off
because it's like you know when you have
a master chef you know you gotta cater
to the chef and you gotta cater to the
customers when you have pilots you gotta
cater to the pilots and the passengers
you know same thing with physicians you
got to cater to the patients and the
physicians so you have to be thoughtful
about what it means to be a physician
and it is tough to be a physician in
general particularly United States where
reimbursement the more you do the more
you get paid and the the payments have
been kind of relatively flat on a flat
on a fee-for-service real storm basis
and so if you're in primary care which
is reimbursed at a relatively lower
amount because you're not doing as many
procedures it is a tough job and so what
we tried to do was first create some
more airspace in the schedule so the
physician can be a little bit more their
best self it's still hard I mean at one
medical our practitioners see about
fifteen or sixteen patients a day which
is much better than 25 to 30 if you go
to the average primary care physician
they need to see about 25-30 patients a
day to make an income where they can
afford a house and a lot of high income
neighborhoods you know but it's it's
it's you know it's a lot of work if you
think about and the way I describe this
to people who don't know what it's like
to be a clinician is if you go to an
average business person how many days do
you have in any given day where you have
20 appointments right or 20 meetings a
day and imagine if you had even just one
day where you're booked it basically 20
minute slots all day long every half
hour less than that right so so 20 you
know if you're booked in every 20
minutes you're going to see 25 patients
in you know 24 meetings a day and you
did that every day
of your life you know four to five days
a week to make your income and the
income stayed about the same
incrementally over you know in real term
basis right so that's what it's like to
be a physician today particularly
primary care and we reduced it to about
fifteen or sixteen they're still doing
some emails in between so it is still a
very busy day for an average
practitioner and the responsibility is
high right because your take caring for
people's lives if somebody comes in with
depression if somebody comes in with
suicidal risk you can't it's really hard
to say sorry you know twenty minutes you
know you're diagnosed with HIV or cancer
like to you know it's it's really a
tough profession that people don't
really fully appreciate and so we made
it better so that helps and then we also
focus on hiring clinicians and primary
care Doc's that would really kind of
practice the style of medicine we think
is the highest quality of medicine again
that's a charged word quality like how
do you define quality medicine people
associate quality in terms of you know
check box lists and and and pedigrees
and number of research articles but at
the end of the day you know our thesis
set one medical is quality is the
ability to listen in here we as a
primary care clinician you need to be
able to communicate and listen and
understand the issues the medicine is in
the medicine like most people have a
pretty good fundamental knowledge of
Medicine where where clinicians fall off
is where they're either too busy burnt
out they don't care enough yeah well
they don't listen enough and if you're
not listening enough then you're not
really understanding the core problem
and you're not really solving the
fundamental issue for the patient's so a
lot of it is giving our clinicians the
time resources and really the mindset to
really care for patients thoughtfully
and that's where you discover the
undiscovered cancer the undiscovered
depression the undiscovered XYZ that
ultimately changes the trajectory of an
individual's health and yeah those are
the stories that I love hearing about
from our patients
yeah whoa so by changing the
physician-patient experience from the
two 20-minute time slots perverse
incentive systems thus type of stuff
when we transition it more - I'm here to
listen and get to the first principle
things that are happening within you
that are causing you to feel the ways
that you are and actually healing
people's life trajectories towards
health Wow
that's what's up yeah it is cool I mean
kudos and credit goes to our team like
this happens because our clinicians are
great our support teams are great you
know our general tech and product and
corporate team they all work as one
giant team to make it all work and at
friends center is the clinician with the
patient but you know that's where you
know that payout comes and you know it's
fun to see it's great and now what is
the your ability to provide ten times
better healthcare at one-third the cost
how does how does someone do that
yeah that's obviously shorthand it's
really hard to measure these things but
the cost side is pretty clear meaning
you know most people would say this is a
great sort of experience you know so I
think people would agree that the
service level is certainly much better
than the average doctor's office the
cost side is is much lower in the sense
that we've redesigned the whole practice
and none of it is easy but you can run
it apples to apples and it's a
combination of two things one is most
physician practices aren't really won't
run very efficiently or well if you go
to the average doctor's office you see
people running with paper and or
antiquated machinery and systems it's
not hard to see why it's a little bit
inefficient right and going back to kind
of our earlier statement stacks aren't
trained to be businesspeople managers
they're trying to be scientists and
you know compassionate individuals so
it's not surprise and then when you take
a really complicated insurance
reimbursement system and ask physicians
to lead them in small practices it's not
really a recipe for success so part of
the physician practice is they've over
hired labor to manage a process that
ends up being more an inefficient and
then they need to see more patients to
support the labor costs so it's kind of
a ratchet and so it's really hard to
unwind that when you're busy
practitioner we started from scratch I
had obviously a business background and
we were pretty neurotic that every kind
of thing that we did to support you know
patient workflow and administrative we
would do it better faster and smarter
using technology so by using kind of
better system design and technology it
allowed us to lower our overhead while
not sacrificing anything on quality and
service we and so that generated a
margin that allows us to take on you
know professional capital which allows
us to expand and grow more quickly than
the average doctor's office so all these
things were necessary components to make
the model work and then give us a bit on
the the efficiencies that the physicians
have within their work with patients the
electronic health record or medical
record is something that's really big
and you know Rob Lustig's on the show
and he's talking about how bad it is
like lack the lack of eye contact when I
have to take notes as a physician at the
same time so yep teach us about because
the future seems like it's being able to
take a voice to text transcription and
parse it for those kids health care
points and you know stuff like that
sure so certainly you know at one lot of
who we designed our own electronic
health record back then that was a bit
of you know her ethically people were
like you're doing what you know you got
whole companies with hundreds if not
thousands of engineers billions of
capital invested and you're gonna start
up an EHR within a practice model right
most people thought that was pretty
crazy and we were probably the first to
really pioneer that and it was early
tech days you know this is really
old stack Ruby on Rails type of tech but
we built it and it was a good v1 and
then we've migrated it over time we're
now almost fully upgraded to the new
system which is I think one of the best
in class EHRs out there and it's
designed because you know the reason why
it's so much better it's designed
towards speed and usability most EHRs
are designed to sell more EHRs and so
how do you sell EHRs well you check all
the boxes and it has this many features
and the procurement team checks you know
hey it has these systems and the
perverse incentive yeah so there's
really a lot of weird stuff out there
and they're not really designed to meet
the clinicians needs they're really just
designed to check the boxes of all the
constituents who make the purchasing
decision on what tech systems to do and
frankly there aren't that many options
most of the tech systems are really
mediocre so it's not surprising that
there's a whole uproar about when you
remember what we talked about most
clinicians are on a 25 to 30 patient day
schedule in primary care so that already
is not a recipe for success it doesn't
matter how fast it jar is you got very
little turnaround time it's like
imagining you know that you got to turn
around a plane in 30 seconds it doesn't
matter what you know garbage bags and
gloves you got you still about 30
seconds to turn around a plane no
different like there's there's no speed
system there so one night ago we
obviously only see 15 or 16 patients
today more airspace yeah more time
between visits to kind of really
thoughtfully put stuff in and then the
design of the system is much faster and
you know I would argue that it's
probably one of the best systems out
there today and those all work together
but you know it doesn't come for free
you know the margins attract the capital
which allow us to invest in the software
design okay what that's all right not if
you're an average practice it's really
hard to design your own HR today it's a
little bit easier the tech stack is a
lot more scalable and efficient today
yeah
and then the physicians even though
they're only seeing 15 instead of 30
patients they can still afford to have
like a mortgage and whatnot as well yeah
so their comp is at the top end of the
scale for primary care and it's still
you know look the economic equation of
being a primary care physician is still
not super optimal because most medical
schools put people into you know
hundreds of thousands of dollars of debt
you're in a non-income-generating
environment for seven years post-college
yeah building up a debt and then you're
starting to generate an income so you
know people don't go on a medicine
because they want to make money they
want to take care of patients and
economic equations are increasingly
challenging in the past say we're
probably almost too fat it was almost
too rich of a job and it's leaned down
enough where now the equations a little
bit more a challenging which is why you
see a lot of med students and end up
being specialists and things like
becoming a generalist the insurance
reimbursement systems these things the
correcting the perverse incentives these
things are slowly happening in
healthcare and it's cool to have
entrepreneurs that are also physicians
that take the reins and say that we know
how to design this better um that leads
us to Galileo yeah all right so what's
happening this is a year and a half for
you now yeah and so Galileo's building
the future of health care let's keep
teach us about this yeah so we're still
a little bit under wraps I don't like to
kind of talk about stuff until we've got
more validated so we'll be able to share
a little bit but you know if you think
about health care today we're at this
kind of threshold of amazing stuff
happening in terms of some of the
genomic stuff you know the microbiome
how we understand lifestyle and our
thesis is health care still is big and
broken and there's a future health care
system to be designed and built and one
medical is you know a way to kind of say
hey how do you make the parents
better Galileo was really an opportunity
to say how would we vision it kind of
envision a future healthcare system and
how do we design that and build that
today so it's really a future forward
model and it's got you know two core
components one is you know it's not hard
to see but you know we think the future
of healthcare is going to require some
clinical intelligence right through tech
and so how do you start designing and
building a framework around that so that
we can make smarter better faster
decisions that are higher quality given
an overwhelming amount of data on any
individual so that's kind of one aspect
of what we're building so then you need
to get a purse you need to get my
biometrics on like a constant stream
basically through technology and then be
able to maybe predict yeah yeah one can
imagine a future state where that kind
of system exists right and so we're
really early days on that but that's
kind of how we think about where the
future of medicine should be which is
how do you take this and really move it
into a higher quality more personalized
small writes all the stuff you hear
about and talk about but what does that
really look like tangibly and how do you
actually fund it and what are the
economics of it it's it's you know it
sounds great in the abstract but in
practice you got to make it work so
that's one part of it so we have this
kind of kind of tech heavy component to
clinical intelligence but the important
part about it is you know and the
primary motivation to starting Galileo
is there's a vast number of folks mostly
the complex and underserved that don't
have access to the care model that they
need right so if you think about one
medical it's great for the 80% of the
population that is able to manage their
care schedule an appointment go to the
doctor and get most of their needs met
and then follow through but there's
about 20% of the population that is too
sick to under serve to under resourced
to really manage their healthcare and
they end up costing the healthcare
system 80% of the dollar right yeah the
whole Pareto principle so basically what
we're trying to do is
is design a care system explicitly for
the most complex and underserved so
that's what that rule is and so okay so
what what does it look like talking
about the underserved under-resourced
yeah I mean ultimately we think that's a
bit more of how do you translate
healthcare right it's not necessarily
knowledge of Medicine like that's I
think clear it's how do you make it
actually happen and that's a really hard
thing to do so we don't have the answers
yet we're still early when I'm talking
about how we're doing it yet yeah but
the approach is really being you know
similar in mindset to one medical think
about who you're you know patient is
think about the ecosystem in which they
live how do you really meet them where
they are and solve their problems so
that they are healthier and hopefully
lower cost for the healthcare system
because then the savings can then be
exact lied to other problems yeah so not
only we do we get the healthier people
but then a vast majority of the spending
gets opened up for other things
education all of their eyes you can do a
lot more things so right now the system
is just poorly designed to take care of
the sick and complex I mean I've worked
in a lot of the best health care systems
in the country and the practice
architecture is really not designed to
really proactively care for the sick and
so we hope that come to the office we
hope they follow up with that cardiology
appointment we hope they're able to get
the right resources to show up to X Y &
Z appointments and in reality it's
really hard for people who are of lower
income means or have really it you know
really established clinical complexity
and it's just overwhelming for a lot of
individuals and so I think we're really
trying to design a high test model for
that patient love the work and future of
healthcare couple quick questions on the
way out of the episode first one is what
do you think happens pre birth and post
death
whoa we just shifted gears pre-birth and
post-death my guess is it's one in the
same I don't have a great descriptor for
it but I do again I haven't dug a lot
you know I don't spend a lot of time
reading into this but my feeling and
intuition is there's an energy force
that we haven't fully captured and that
energy force is the difference you know
that of all these other intangibles that
we don't helpfully account for it
my feeling is that's the energy force
and so you know there's an intangible
that's pre and post and I'd like to sit
yes yeah I'd like to believe that that
is kind of an energy force that we kind
of morph into but you know we'll have to
see what happens yeah next question is
do you do you think we're in a
simulation yeah geez I mean I don't want
to offend but I think that's a bit
ridiculous personally I just think that
that's people probably overthinking you
know reality sure it's it's an a mine F
to kind of think about it that way but I
think that's probably there's no way
obviously prove it but I just think it's
it's fun to mentally toy with but I'm
just cynical and I just think that's
just kind of ridiculous and the last
question what do you think is the most
beautiful are these universal questions
you ask everybody I usually you should
take a tally I'd love to see what the
tally yeah there's been 420 plus of
these answered so oh yeah later we'll go
in yeah yeah well this is why we really
have the database and then we'll go
apart scrape it for the although
important information like this last
question is what's the most beautiful
thing in the world
Oh
for me personally I think a space and
moon you know like the the ability at
times like an eclipse is a classic
example we when the lighting is just
clear and right that you realize that we
are just a rounding error in our solar
system let alone the universe and so for
me that's always an awe-inspiring and
beautiful almost at any moment you know
when you get a full appreciation for you
know the kind of the ridiculousness of
our you know little daily human problems
so I love I love just the the context of
space yeah this has been such a fun
episode talk thank you so much for
coming on and able to do it glad we were
able to do it and for all those that
watch huge thank you we greatly
appreciate you watching give us your
thoughts in the comments below on the
future of healthcare I'd love to hear
from you also please check out the links
below one medical comm Galileo also
Thomas LinkedIn profile get talking with
your friends your families your
co-workers people online on social media
about a lot of things that Tom mentioned
in the episode get chatting about them
get spreading these things around more
people about the future of health care
and huge shout out to Ron Vargas for
producing and directing Thank You Ronny
we really appreciate it yeah and
everyone support the artists
entrepreneurs and organizations around
the world that you believe in support
simulation our links are below help us
grow and prosper as well and go and
build the future everyone manifest your
dreams into the world thank you for
tuning in and we will see you soon peace
[Music]
you